[Music]
i think their passion
you really need it to create something
on a particular level
you need to give everything from
yourself in there
and that's the difference i think
this book means for me that i discuss
really with the client what he wants you
have
ideas here you can see different
materials
different models it's very important to
listen
and nowadays many people don't listen
anymore
the last is really the copy of your foot
on which we create the shoe
but nobody shows you how to make a last
really so you have to
train it by yourself and to get the
feeling by yourself how you should do it
you have certain measurements from the
foot but the feeling of the client
is always different
i love using the leather because you you
get this
particular different touches
what i appreciate so much from this
tannery is they use a swiss cart
maybe it's because it's cold and these
animals live
on a very high level in the mountains
it's always a cow but
cows are also different i think it's
something which you can wear
for a long time and the leather the more
you wear it
it really gets more life i think
i will draw the model from the client
and
this drawing i will translate then on a
flat
paper model which i put on the leather
and we sew it together and from there we
start creating really
the shoe
i think the hand craft and this
concentration of different
craftsmanships in florence is really
um coming up from the medici family
if it's a jeweler or if it's a painter
or
a sculpture maker they always try to
to get the best artisans in town
the upper will be nailed and pulled over
the last
i will start sewing with linen thread
which is
made kind of waterproof with wax when
you stitch
you have two threads which go into the
same hole
and as you pull the wax goes hot it will
seal together
so the water cannot go through and this
is a very particular and very old
process
it's very rare to be a woman in this
shoemaking world
when i started everybody looked at me
and said this lady is going to close
down in a year
a woman in a man's job it's not going to
work and
now they're all proud in the in this
area that i'm still here
we fill in the wooden shank and the back
support because that is the part
under the curve of your foot which will
not be bent
so it has to be supportive and stiff
the front part we will fill with cork
this is to give you a bit of cushion
effect as you bend it the whole time
it's important to have it soft
we apply the sole we will glue it on
and afterwards make a channel we will
stitch
the weld and the leather sole together
through the channel
so it gets more shape of the shoe and
you see it more as a finished product
when we work normally in the workshop
it's a very calm
feeling we are in kind of a meditation
because you are so concentrated on what
you do
you can feel that all of a sudden the
energy comes down
everybody is concentrated on his
particular step
the last big step to put on is the heel
which will be
built out of single layers of leather
we will glue them and nail them on
and then cut them in shape and at the
end we pass some glass
sanding it and then
burn it with hot irons so all the pores
are going to be completely closed up
the last step is to shine the whole shoe
and then we can pull out the last
and then the client can work
[Music]
if you count the hours we would work
around
three weeks on one pair of shoes
when i see a finished shoe and the
client really
tries it on it's always the moment of
reality and relief if it really fits
well
when this person is really happy oh you
can just
see at their eyes without explaining
that that's
the best feeling ever
i think a shoe is more than an object
a shoe really reflects the person who's
wearing it
the leather they choose the color they
choose
and how they wear it because not just
the pear in the beginning it's the pear
over
many many years
you